en esta ocasión quiero hablarles sobre
los diagramas él o él me escucharon bien
diagramas l o l estos diagramas son una
excelente manera de visualizar la
conservación de la energía y algo mejor
nos obligan a considerar que forma parte
de nuestro sistema de energía y que no y
si no conocen lo que es un sistema de
energía creo que por aquí debemos
comenzar un sistema de energía es un
objeto o colección de objetos de los
cuales vamos a estar registrando su
energía vamos a estarlo registrando en
este tipo de diagramas y noten que uno
tiene una forma de l que se parece una o
y aquí hay otra l por eso se les llama
diagramas l o l
este es un diagrama de energía aquí
vamos a dibujar nuestro sistema y aquí
tenemos otro diagrama de energía y para
conocer la utilidad de estos diagramas l
o l vamos a ver un ejemplo digamos que
tenemos esto una masa que está a una
altura h y la cual se encuentra en
reposo pero yo en un momento la voy
liberar la voy a soltar de esta altura h
y cuando la suelte esta masa va a caer
lo primero que tenemos que hacer es
elegir que va a formar parte de nuestro
sistema de energía un elemento por
ejemplo va a ser nuestra masa que vamos
a poner aquí aquí voy a poner todos los
elementos que me interesa registrar su
energía y fuera de esto van a estar
aquellos elementos que no voy a
registrar su energía entonces
típicamente en estos problemas las
personas van a considerar la masa como
parte del sistema de energía sobre todo
si estamos viendo la conservación de la
energía aquí vamos a comenzar con
energía potencial que después va a
transformarse en energía cinética y
debido a esto vamos a registrar la
energía que tiene esta masa y si
hablamos de energía potencial también
vamos a hablar aunque les parezca
extraño de la tierra aquí está nuestro
planeta tierra con sus continentes y
todo y también va a formar parte de
nuestro sistema de energía
y ya aquí tenemos nuestro sistema vamos
a comenzar a graficar las energías
involucradas aquí al inicio qué energía
vamos a tener aquí vamos a tener energía
potencial gravitacional ya que esta masa
m se encuentra suspendida una altura h y
esa altura h está por encima de la
tierra
ahora vamos a graficar esta energía como
una barra y esta barra tiene cuatro
unidades son cuatro unidades de energía
potencial gravitacional y me pueden
decir cómo es que sabes que son
exactamente cuatro unidades porque no
dos o porque no tres y media
aquí la cantidad exacta no importa
demasiado en estos días más l o l lo
importante es poder conceptualizar qué
es lo que está sucediendo con estas
energías no importa que dibujemos acá
tenemos que ser consistentes cuando lo
dibujemos en este otro diagrama y en un
momento les explicaré qué significa esto
así que digamos que aquí tenemos al
inicio cuatro unidades de energía
potencial gravitación
tenemos algo de energía cinética no ya
que esta masa se encontraba en reposo
cuando la liberamos si yo suelto esta
masa va a comenzar con velocidad cero y
esta u s se refiere a la energía del
resorte o energía elástica que no va a
aplicar en este ejemplo ya que no
tenemos ningún resorte o energía
elástica así que esta es toda la energía
que tenemos al inicio qué va a pasar con
esta energía bueno tenemos que nuestra
posición inicial es esta qué tipo de
energía vamos a tener cuando la masa
esté a punto de tocar el suelo hasta
este punto final
en este punto justo antes de que la masa
de con el suelo vamos a tener energía
cinética ya que esta masa se estaba
moviendo desde que la soltamos y la
energía cinética es la energía que tiene
un objeto debido a su movimiento con
cuánta energía cinética vamos a terminar
bueno ya que la energía se conserva si
yo tengo cuatro unidades de energía
gravitacional
voy a terminar con cuatro unidades de
energía cinética y quizá esto nos
confunda y me pregunten bueno porque no
tenemos al final energía potencial
gravitacional bueno aquí estamos
suponiendo que esta línea es la línea
cuando h es igual a cero y sabemos que
la energía potencial gravitacional es
igual a m por g por h y en este caso
está h es igual a 0 por lo que aquí no
tenemos energía potencial gravitacional
así que cuando esta masa llega al punto
final que es lo que estoy representando
con este diagrama entonces mi energía
potencial gravitacional en este punto va
a ser cero y ya que aquí al final no
tenemos ningún tipo de energía potencial
gravitacional entonces quiere decir que
toda esta energía potencial
gravitacional del inicio se transformó
en energía cinética esto tiene que
suceder así para que se conserve la
energía de nuestro sistema
ustedes me pueden decir a ver un momento
anteriormente aprendimos que cuando se
realiza un trabajo la energía se
transfiere y la energía total de un
objeto puede cambiar la tierra está
ejerciendo una fuerza de gravedad en
este objeto hacia abajo esta masa se
está moviendo hacia abajo con cierta
velocidad por lo que la tierra está
realizando cierto trabajo positivo sobre
la masa es decir le está proporcionando
energía con este trabajo y si esto
ocurre no significa que la energía de mi
sistema va a cambiar pues no y la razón
de esto es que nuestra tierra forma
parte de nuestro sistema de energía está
incluida en él así que aunque la tierra
está realizando un trabajo positivo en
la masa y proporcionándole energía
cinética la tierra forma parte de este
sistema y este trabajo va a ser un
trabajo interno y el trabajo interno en
un sistema nunca nos va a aceptar
ya que tiene este para aclarar esto
imagínense que aquí están ustedes y aquí
está un amigo y tú le das a tu amigo 200
pesos a lo mejor pues tú perdiste 200
pesos y el amigo ganó 200 pesos pero si
los dos forman parte del sistema el
dinero que hay entre los dos no va a
cambiar la cantidad de dinero que hay en
este sistema no ha cambiado esto mismo
se cumple cuando estamos hablando de
energías si tenemos energías internas
dentro de un sistema de energía estas no
me van a afectar las energías que tengo
de una gráfica a la otra y es por eso
que tuve que dibujar mi energía cinética
con cuatro unidades para que se
conservará la energía inicial ya que
ninguna energía externa entró o salió de
nuestro sistema y algo muy bueno de
estos diagramas l eau l es que podemos
transformarlos directamente en
ecuaciones de conservación de la energía
que cualquier energía inicial que
tengamos más cualquier cantidad de
trabajo externo que encontremos esto va
a ser igual a la energía final del
sistema y esto es porque el trabajo
externo se refiere a qué cantidad de
trabajo se transfirió hacia nuestro
sistema si comenzamos con 10 usos de
energía y nos transfirieron desde afuera
5 llull de energía al final vamos a
tener 15 de energía y si aplicamos esto
para nuestro ejemplo tendremos como
energía inicial nuestra energía
potencial gravitacional que es m por g
por h más energía externa pero aquí no
hubo energía externa sólo tuvimos
trabajo interno así que esto va a ser
cero y esto tiene que ser igual a la
energía final y esto es igual a la única
energía que tengo aquí al final que es
mi energía cinética que es un medio por
m por b al cuadrado y si aquí tuviéramos
números los podríamos sustituir y podría
despejar no sé a lo mejor está h o esta
vez o lo que queramos saber cómo se
vería un ejemplo en donde tuviéramos un
trabajo externo o en donde no se
conservará la energía bueno puede usar
este mismo ejemplo pero solamente
quitando a mi tierra y la dejará fuera
de mi sistema de energía por lo que
ahora mi sistema sería únicamente la
masa m y ahora el trabajo realizado por
la tierra en la masa va a ser un trabajo
externo y ahora que tengo un trabajo
externo que está afectando mi sistema
pues la energía inicial ya no va a ser
la misma que la energía final la energía
de mi sistema ya no se va a conservar
porque hay algo externo que le está
dando energía la tierra le está
proporcionando un trabajo externo a la
masa y esto va a cambiar nuestro
diagrama leo l nuestra masa va a seguir
teniendo energía cinética el hecho de
que ya no consideremos a la tierra como
parte de nuestro sistema no va a cambiar
lo que sucede con estos elementos
la masa va a seguir bajando hasta acá
con cuatro unidades de energía cinética
va a seguir bajando como lo hacía
anteriormente pero ahora nuestro sistema
de energía va a estar ganando energía
como es esto posible
puedes diciendo que nuestra masa no va a
iniciar con la energía potencial
gravitacional y hay muchas personas esto
no les gusta dicen a ver cómo es posible
de que la masa no tenga energía
potencial gravitacional y por supuesto
que esta masa va a comenzar con energía
potencial gravitacional y técnicamente
hablando la energía potencial
gravitacional es una energía que existe
entre dos masas se requieren dos para
bailar el tango y se requieren dos masas
para tener energía potencial
gravitacional y si una de estas masas
está fuera del sistema va a ser un
trabajo externo en la masa y esto no lo
puedo poner aquí porque solo son las
energías iniciales
el sistema de energía por lo que ahora
este término va a ser cero pero ahora sí
podemos decir que hay una energía
externa este es el trabajo realizado por
la tierra sobre la masa cuál es la
cantidad de trabajo externo realizado
por la tierra sobre la masa bueno si mi
energía final fue de 4 unidades entonces
el trabajo externo fue de 4 así que si
quitamos a la tierra de nuestro sistema
de energía nuestra gráfica de energía
inicial no va a tener ninguna energía
pero ahora vamos a tener un trabajo
externo realizado por la tierra sobre la
masa que ponemos aquí y quizás a ustedes
les confunda esto ya que pues tenemos la
misma situación lo único que hicimos fue
no considerar a la tierra como parte de
nuestro sistema de energía y esto cómo
afecta a nuestros cálculos pues
realmente no nos afecta ahora en lugar
de tener nuestra energía potencial
gravitacional m&g por h de 4 unidades
esto ya no lo tengo pero ahora tengo un
trabajo externo de 4 unidades de energía
son dos perspectivas diferentes pero
aquí tenemos exactamente las mismas
cantidades vamos a tener el mismo
resultado todo esto va a ser consistente
pero dependiendo de si ustedes
consideran a la tierra como parte del
sistema de energía o no pues me va a
implicar que puedo yo decir que tengo
una energía potencial gravitacional
inicial si la considero como parte de mi
sistema de energía o puedo decir que no
tengo esta energía inicial pero tengo un
trabajo externo que está siendo
realizado en mi masa vamos a ver otro
ejemplo vamos a quitar esto
ahora consideremos este ejemplo en donde
nuestra masa está comprimiendo un
resorte se encuentra en reposo y este va
a ser nuestro punto inicial de pronto
soltamos esta masa que pasa por este
plano inclinado y luego va a seguir por
acá con cierta velocidad y aquí será
nuestro punto final y para crear nuestro
diagrama el eo l lo primero que tenemos
que hacer es determinar que vamos a
considerar como parte de nuestro sistema
de energía ya que si no tenemos definido
estos elementos no podremos saber qué
cosas rastrear para poder llenar estos
diagramas de acá nuevamente vamos a
hacer que nuestra masa forme parte de
nuestro sistema de energía también vamos
a hacer que el resorte forme parte del
sistema
vamos a hacer que también la tierra
forme parte del sistema cómo se va a ver
este diagrama l o l para este escenario
bueno inicialmente tendremos nuestra
masa en reposo y aún cuando la tierra
forma parte de nuestro sistema y pudiera
tener la masa cierta energía potencial
gravitación
yo estoy suponiendo que esta parte de
aquí este nivel es mi h igual a 0 es
decir este es el suelo por lo que mi
término de energía potencial
gravitacional m g por h va a ser cero ya
que h es igual a cero así que no voy a
tener energía potencial gravitacional
aquí y entonces la única energía que
tengo de entrada es la de este resorte
comprimido que está listo para explotar
y aventar esta masa por acá entonces
tengo mi energía del resorte o mi
energía elástica y vamos a decir que
aquí tengo cinco unidades de energía de
esta energía elástica aquí yo estoy
eligiendo cantidades aleatoriamente pero
en un problema en donde les den
cantidades pues van a graficar las
cantidades exactas y recordemos que la
energía elástica o del resorte se define
como un medio por k por x al cuadrado
de x es la distancia en la que estamos
comprimiendo el resorte y acá es la
constante del resorte pero para mantener
simple este ejemplo vamos a decir que
comenzamos con 5 unidades de energía
elástica y cuáles serán las energías al
final bueno sabemos que esta masa se va
a liberar va a ser empujada por el
resorte va a pasar por esta rampa y va a
llegar aquí a mi punto final así que la
masa va a estar en movimiento por lo que
voy a tener energía cinética si
quisiéramos saber exactamente cuál es la
cantidad de energía cinética pues
tendríamos que resolver para los valores
específicos de este problema y conocer
la altura pero para darnos una idea de
lo que dice la conservación de la
energía digamos que al final vamos a
tener tres unidades de energía cinética
otra energía que vamos a tener aquí al
final es la energía potencial
gravitacional ya que esta masa va a
terminar a cierta altura por encima de h
igual a cero así que como tengo mi masa
elevada a cierta altura pues voy a tener
energía potencial gravitacional y si yo
digo que inicie con cinco unidades de
energía elástica y estoy terminando con
tres unidades de energía cinética pues
para mantener la conservación de la
energía más me vale terminar con dos
unidades de energía potencial
gravitacional
así que si comienzo con cinco unidades
de energía debo terminar en total con
cinco unidades de energía ya que esto me
va a decir que la energía se está
conservando cómo podemos saber si se va
a conservar la energía dentro de mi
sistema pues voy a revisar si es que hay
alguna otra fuerza o trabajo externo que
me esté afectando lo que tengo aquí si
no hay ningún elemento de energía
externo que esté afectando a mi sistema
esta energía se va a conservar si aquí
tengo cinco unidades
aquí también deberé tener cinco unidades
y si suponemos que esta superficie de
aquí no tiene
y no hay resistencia al aire y tampoco
tenemos ninguna pérdida de energía por
fuerzas que se estén disipando no
tendremos trabajo externo ya que todos
los elementos forman parte de nuestro
sistema y aunque aquí el resorte le
proporciona trabajo a la masa es un
trabajo interno pero como no tengo
ningún trabajo externo la energía se va
a conservar y esto podemos escribirlo
como una ecuación podemos decir que la
energía inicial que es la energía del
resorte un medio por k por x al cuadrado
más el trabajo externo que está
afectando mi sistema pero como aquí no
tengo ningún trabajo externo esto va a
ser cero eso tiene que ser igual a mi
energía final y aquí tengo como parte de
mi energía final mi energía cinética que
es un medio por m por b al cuadrado
la energía potencial gravitacional que
es m por g por h y si aquí nos dieran
cantidades la sustituiríamos en esta
ecuación y despejar y amos cualquier
variable que nos interese conocer pero
ustedes se pueden preguntar qué pasaría
si hubiera fricción entre la rampa y la
masa si aquí hubiera fricción entonces
qué haríamos bueno hay dos formas en las
que podemos resolver esto podemos
considerar que estas dos superficies
forman parte de nuestro sistema o
podemos considerar que estas superficies
no forman parte del sistema si estas
superficies no formarán parte de nuestro
sistema esto significaría que están
quitando energía de mi sistema hay un
trabajo externo negativo en lugar de que
mi trabajo externo le esté
proporcionando energía a mi sistema se
le está quitando la fricción me va a
estar quitando energía y la va a
transformar en energía térmica y es por
eso que tenemos este lugar aquí para la
energía térmica
pero como esas superficies no son parte
de nuestro sistema no le incluiremos acá
simplemente sería parte de nuestro
trabajo externo aquí tendríamos una
cantidad negativa de trabajo no sé a lo
mejor es menos un unidades de energía de
trabajo externo esto quiere decir que si
comenzamos con 5 unidades de energía y
tuvimos trabajo externo que nos quitó
una unidad de energía aquí solamente
vamos a terminar con 4 unidades de
energía pero mi energía potencial
gravitacional tiene que ser la misma
estoy terminando a esta altura esto no
va a cambiar lo que significa que mi
energía cinética va a hacerse más
pequeña lo que tiene sentido ya que la
fricción va a hacer que mi masa vaya más
lenta así que aquí termino con 4
unidades de energía a pesar de que
comencé con 5 ya que tuvimos una unidad
negativa de energía porque tuvimos un
trabajo externo que fue realizado por la
fricción en estas superficies pero
que esta era sólo una forma de
conceptualizar lo ahora en lugar de
pensar que estas superficies no forman
parte de nuestro sistema de energía
ahora podemos considerar que son parte
de nuestro sistema de manera que este
trabajo externo ya no existe ya no tengo
trabajo externo y ahora este trabajo va
a ser interno estas superficies siguen
quitando energía pero como ahora son
parte de mi sistema este trabajo va a
ser un trabajo interno y ahora como
representamos esto si ya no tengo mi
menos una unidad de energía aquí bueno
conceptualmente quitamos este menos 1
sumando un 1 en ambos lados de la
igualdad y eso significa que ganamos
cierta energía térmica que estoy
escribiendo como delta
térmica ya que tendremos cierta ganancia
de energía térmica en nuestro sistema y
esto lo voy a representar no como un
trabajo externo sino como una
de energía térmica que fue generada
durante este proceso el resumen los
diagramas l son una gran herramienta
para visualizar de lo que hablamos
cuando nos referimos a la conservación
de la energía y cómo definimos lo que es
nuestro sistema de energía ahora sí
podemos conceptualizar cuando decimos
que la energía total inicial que tenemos
en nuestro sistema más cualquier trabajo
externo realizado en nuestro sistema
tiene que ser igual a la energía total
final en el sistema